[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Соля та
сьогодні Совеня знову прийшло вчасно
адже ми будемо говорити на дуже солодку
і цікаву тему Як ти думаєш сьогодні про
що ми будемо говорити
Ой не знаю пані солю про морозиво не
зовсім
про солоденьке щось так це буде
солоденьке і це буде щось дуже таке
натуральне солоденьке що виготовляють
певні комашки з
Ану друзі Може ви знаєте про що ми
будемо говорити я знаю я знаю Будемо
говорити
про медочок А ще про дуже працьовитих
і
молодець Совеня його друзі Отож Соня а
ти собі тут посидь з бочку А ми будемо з
вами дізнаватися як же ж виготовляється
медочок І що ж ті бджоли роблять Давайте
починати Отож перш за все в мене ось тут
є бджоли
Ну вони не гудуть але справжні бджоли
гудуть і у нас тут є вулик і давайте ми
з вами
спершу дізнаємося історію про те як
бджоли
потрапляють на квітки бо ми друзі часто
бачимо що бджоли є на квіточках щось там
собі гудуть збирають Але що ж
відбувається насправді Тож давайте ми
розпочнемо Отож я у нас бджола
бджола вилітає зі свого вулика Ось тут в
нас з вулика вилетіла наша бджілка
вилетіла вилетіла вилетіла і бджілка
прилетіла до квіточки І що роблять
бджоли бджоли збирають з квіток
спеціальний нектар що таке нектар нектар
це така водичка яка є на квіточках і
бджоли і п'ють цю водичку Тобто це їхня
їжа і також з неї виготовляють мед
давайте Ми подумаємо якщо бджілка сіла
на квіточку чи одразу в нас утворюється
мед
Ні ще не утворюється для цього потрібно
ще дуже багато всього зробити коли
бджілка сіли на квіточку
зібрала з квіточки нектар
вона летить назад до вулика але до іншої
бджілки І знаєте що робить своїм ротиком
передає нектар від бджілки до бджілки
друзі і Що відбувається далі Коли
бджілка бджілці передала весь нектар і
вже здається Він дуже наближений до меду
то Як ви думаєте ми вживаємо мед чи ще
не маємо
молодці ще не маємо адже опісля
бджілка летить до спеціальної хатинки до
вулика в якому є
воскові стільники друзі Гляньте уважно
ось ці маленькі дірочки це власне є
посудинки для нашого майбутнього меду
щоб ви друзі розуміли
стільники є ідеальної форми вони є у
формі шестикутника якщо глянути уважно
на зображення ви побачите що всі вони
такі знаєте як один єдиний зроблені
однаковісінько Ось тут в мене є ще одне
зображення дивіться друзі і це насправді
не є круглі ручки це є шестикутник і
давайте ми зараз його намалюємо
[музика]
один два
три
чотири
п'ять шість
ось такий у нас щестикутник який має 6
кутів давайте разом порахуємо 1 2 3 4 5
6 Ось у такій формі у нас є стільник в
формі шестикутника так друзі
повертаємось до наших бджілок Отож
бджілка принесла свій нектар вже у
вулик
і друзі в цьому вулику Вона залишає
нектар який був у неї в ротику Як ви
думаєте тоді в нас вже утворився мед чи
ще ні
так друзі ще не утворився далі
бджілки знаєте що роблять
махають крильцями для того аби мед який
є у стільниках почав
загустівати і перетворюватись на той мед
який ми з вами знаємо давайте покажемо
як би ми махали крильцями якби були
бджілками Ось так сильно-сильно вони
махають крильцями і завдяки вітру який
створюють крильця бджіл цей мед
загустіває і вже пізніше з часом коли
дуже довго наші бджоли махають крильцями
ми маємо наш звичний медочок далі ми
переходимо До знайомства з дуже цікавою
професією яка називається
Пасічник
Пасічник - це людина яка збирає мед
ось тут у нас є такий пампасічник У
нього є спеціальне вбрання спеціальний
капелюх з сіточкою аби бджоли не
покусали нашого Пасічника і Пасічник
бере наші стільники Ось так друзі
і згодом
зчищає їх у одну посудину
проціджує ситом І після того ми маємо
наш готовий мед Як ви бачите друзі тут у
нас є вулики створені людьми і власне
пасічники створюють такі спеціальні
хатинки вулики для того аби роздобувати
мед
також друзі я вам хочу сказати що
бджоли мають і свої природні вулики і
колись дуже-дуже давно люди не знали як
добувати мед і просто знаєте брали та й
нищили ті вулики відповідно бджоли були
дуже зліта і розгнівані і могли покусати
тих хто міг знищити їхні вулики однак
пізніше Люди зрозуміли що вони можуть з
бджолами
співпрацювати і почали створювати Ось
такі хатинки розводити бджіл і
виготовляти дуже багато меду відповідно
і бджолам добре і людям солодко і смачно
Ось так друзі
також що я хотіла вам сказати
бджоли є неймовірно працьовитими знаєте
чому Тому що одна така бджілка
за один день знаєте скільки разів йде до
квіточки І повертається назад до вулика
60 разів 60 разів це дуже-дуже багато
від вулика до квіточки від вулика до
квіточки от ви друзі Візьміть і
пройдіться 60 разів з одного боку в
інший Ну хоча би 10 Я думаю ви втомитись
уявляєте як наші бджілки втомлюються Я
вважаю неймовірно також друзі ще така
цікавинка від пані солі за один свій
політ тобто від вулика до квіточки на
якесь поле наприклад наша бджілка збирає
нектар з 50 квіток
або навіть і зі ста залежно яка бджілка
раніше прокинулася і швидше почала
працювати І ще дуже дивно що за все своє
життя одна бджілка збирає одну ложку
меду або півтора Тобто це одна і ще пів
уявляєте це все своє життя бджілка така
працьовита літає літає із того всього
виходить лише від одної до півтора ложки
меду це насправді дуже мало
А ще друзі ще одна цікавинка про бджіл
або бджоли дуже цікаві
вулику є неначе своє місто де кожна
бджола робить свою роботу є бджоли
робочі такі які власне літають до квіток
збирають нектари виготовляють Мед є
бджоли будівельники які займаються
будуванням вулика уявляєте А ще є бджола
королева вона є найголовніша і вона
відповідає за те аби народжувалися нові
бджоли Ось така історія друзі Я
сподіваюсь що наступного разу коли ви
будете смакувати медочок ви Пригадайте
ті історії які я вам сьогодні
розповідала
Я дуже люблю медок А ви скажіть хто
любить ми так підніміть ручку
дуже добре Отож друзі будемо з вами
прощатися Давайте поговоримо наше Совеня
щовеня да Совеня Совеня Совеня Совеня
летить на ме
Док Точно ну що ж друзі вам сподобалося
ням-ням Мені також YouTube привітаюся з
бджолами адже вони такі працьовиті А ми
будемо прощатися па-па
па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами науковиця Соломія та
нявка Сьогодні ми експериментуємо і
перед вами дуже прості речі для
експериментів у нас є склянка холодною
водою і гарячою так на гарячу вона
етапна тому друзі можете просто взяти
теплу воду і зараз ми в одну і в іншу
склянку додамо трішки
молодець харчового барвника будь-якого
кольору пішла
перша друга кілька краплинок І тепер в
гарячу
або в теплу Отож друзі Дивіться що в нас
відбувається у нас є холодна вода і
гаряча або досить тепла і в теплій воді
барвник швидше розчиняється і
поєднується з водою ніж в холодній так
само як наприклад у теплій воді швидше
розчиняється цукор ніж в холодній і сіль
чому так відбувається коли ми наливаємо
гарячу воду
молекули такі маленькі частинки які є у
воді починають дуже швидко рухатися в
них з'являється багато енергії вони
рухаються рухаються рухаються і завдяки
тому що вони швидко рухаються вони також
швидше
починають
взаємодіяти з
молекулами фарби барвника іншими словами
відповідно коли вони так це важливо
уточнення відповідно коли вони швидше
рухаються і поєднуються між собою швидше
розчиняється наш барвник і як ви бачите
тут вода вже чітко видно що вона
блакитна а тут наш барвник у холодній
воді лише опустився на дно і по трішечки
Починає розчинятися все завдяки тому що
молекули у теплій воді рухаються значно
швидше Ось так друзі можете вдома також
повторити і подивитися чи у вас
відбудеться так само або наприклад
зробити такий же експеримент з цукром і
з водою і тоді ви будете знати що там за
розчиняються суку швидше там швидкі
молекули рухаються і мають багато
енергії ось так
Ну що ж будемо з вами прощатися гарного
вам дня друзі па-па
[музика]